writing a flawed character for
television versus movies realizing we
need to keep that what's their core
wound and why do they act out of that as
the basis of kind of everything they do
what's the difference between the TV
version of this flawed character and the
movie version the TV will this character
will never actually heal he'll just keep
bleeding there's a great show called the
newsroom Aaron Sorkin really got sick of
the network any any quit making it great
but the first year it's great because
Jeff Daniels is this wounded newspaper
guy and he's been wounded by the girl
who comes in in the pilot to come back
into his life and what Mackenzie tells
him in the pilot is because Jeff Daniels
is playing a guy who's long ago become a
corporate he's like that he calls
himself the Jay Leno of news because he
never wants to be controversial he just
says what he has to say to keep the
ratings up but he's been wounded by this
girl who left him three years ago and we
never told why but she was the soul and
spirit of good journalism she believed
that journalism should be like what it
was here in the 60s where Walter
Cronkite told us the truth about our
society and that's all gone now so Jeff
Daniels is wounded professionally
because he has to become a corporate
every night on the newscast and he
gets good ratings and he's wounded
personally by McKenzie having left him
she comes back in the pilot and says to
him I know you're pissed I know you're
pissed because I left you and you're
right to be pissed but you know what
you've become a and I want you to
become a great newscaster again and I'm
gonna help you because she's a producer
now Jeff Daniels in this pilot he's
furious with her he says to her used we
screwed up
I trusted you he's so angry he can't
even sit down now this wound if it was a
movie by the end of the hour and a half
story he and Mackenzie would have
reconciled you were not only helped him
professionally because she does she
helps him put on a newscast that
actually is truthful and good and
valiant virtuous again but they would
also personally probably either come
together or split apart one of the other
depending on whether you were making a
happy
a tragedy but in television that ending
is just well I think I love you well
I'll see you next week so those wounds
don't heal they just keep bleeding so in
television what replaces the healing of
this heart of this wound his character
surprise something new comes out of the
character you'd never seen come out of
them before in Jeff Daniels character he
surprises us by deciding damn it I am
gonna put on a good newscast I am he
surprised but the very beginning of the
show when he bursts out at Northwestern
in this panel and says we're crap we're
not number one America is not number one
we suck so in television this wound just
continues to bleed for five years I mean
how long did gray on Grey's Anatomy want
to get married I think 10 years I think
she probably got married you're Jenna I
think she's divorced again
so television gives us characters who
actually are a lot more like us in real
life and I think that's another reason
TVs powerful in a way is that we don't
heal generally all in in a month or two
months it's a lifelong process so
wounding and bleeding is kind of the way
we go through life so television shows
us in a way in a way there's more depth
in television than in movies although
movies have real depth to but we can see
week after week facets and surprises of
characters that we would never have time
to see in a movie right the depth of the
Walter White's turns the depths of the
turns we get in Mad Men the way Don
Draper by the way there's a guy who in
the first episode is running away from a
wonderful wife and a family into the
arms of another woman what's he doing
the last season he's running away
love of a wonderful woman and a family
she doesn't really change why do we want
to watch him because he keeps surprising
us
well he's got a new wife Oh certainly
he's gonna be happy now yes season
before no he's gonna go start banging
the upstairs neighbor who's not even
particularly compelling or attractive
why because of his core wound Don
Draper's core wound is I'm unlovable and
we see that when we watch how his mom
that died and he was raised by this
woman who hated him an abusive father
too
now what do you do when you're unlovable
when that's your core wound what is the
behavior and the compensation that comes
out of that well for Don Draper its I'm
gonna become incredibly seductive I'm
gonna be incredibly handsome and
charming I'm gonna make a ton of money
I'm gonna be the most suave
sophisticated guy you could ever meet so
I can just seduce freakin greats amount
of women which he does but what happens
to you when you have that wonderful
woman and that love but your core wound
as I'm unlovable what happens then we
see it with Don wait a minute you love
me you want to be with me what's wrong
with you get away from me I want her I
have to pursue her and we see all that
in season one episode pilot and we see
that through the entire series Don
trying to change and not really being
able to and that sustains the entire
show his core wound literally drives
every episode of the entire story and
this is what core wounds always do this
is why it's the nuclear reactor of a
great character
you